this is the fabulous YouTube channel I'm
James Sinclair and this is Samuel Leeds
you're crazy advocate yeah I'm a crazy
he's a crazy campaigner coming to
Downing Street right now we're at now
right behind there sending letters to
Boris Johnson and you want to not well
you've got a problem with it here
because the things I'm wasting my time
and I'm not wasting my time I've come I
only came here today because I love
James and I please he's a very wealthy
man
and we get dinner we're going out for
dinner but I think they're less tips
crazy man with seven thinks I'm wasting
my time I've come up with a seven-point
plan to help business owners in the SME
sector of the UK to soar to success and
I think there's things that governments
can do to improve the chances of that
happening I don't know why you're not so
no that's a wine you're not doing I'm
not sending a letter I'll tell you why
because number one I don't think Boris
will read it he will he won't he will
anyone how many letters have you wrote
to politicians I would say na by Apple
you have a lot of had replies but you
haven't only change no one's doing
anything different and because this
thing's yeah listen listen listen listen
listen let me give you my reasons number
one I don't think anything you read it
if he does read it he blows me
number two is because I believe that as
a property entrepreneur I think that we
create our own economy but I don't
disagree with that in fact I'm not fully
in the Samuel Leeds choir or creating
your own but the thing is right I'd
rather spend my time and energy yeah go
in looking at a good property deal going
speaking to a good bank to get some to
get a better rate lending I don't want
to be the champion for entrepreneurs cuz
I'm passionate about entrepreneurs and
that's why I do stuff like this also
right I actually think some of the
changes that people are fighting like
the tax change of section 24 and all
these check I actually like them yep
what because it makes it that you don't
have all the charlatans getting in is
that why you sama bar partly but there's
other reasons well section 24 okay
section 26 what do you like about it I
like the fact that everyone thinks that
the tax changes are a bad thing when
actually if you buy through a company
yeah section 20 I'm buying through a
company listen listen right I agree
um so section 20 foot 1
right to Boris and say I don't like
section 24 when I actually love to be
none of my letters about property no
your letter about business but you're
telling me I should write a letter to
Boris about a property well actually I
am doing just fine yeah you know other
than the only thing that I actually when
you see something when you become
someone yeah if you can start
influencing change you should do it it's
you have a responsibility what are their
country your patriotic on you I know I
love what I love it and that's what I'm
doing this stuff alright you know I have
no issues with your letter okay and if
you want to watch James sending his
letter on his channel there'll be a link
somewhere you can check it out and
you'll see it I'm not saying yes she
willed me I did grill yeah because
here's what I think I think that if you
can change something you should change
it yeah if you can't change it then you
should just shut up and get on with your
business you know I'll think semi I
think when I if I set up my business I
when I'm older I felt I'm gonna be ended
up doing something in there I just that
passion you know what maybe you're cool
to politics and and that's great and
that don't want to help them I've done a
hell up go Donald travel really want a
beer
I just want to advise them listen it's
in Donald Trump right he loses a lot of
money by being president of the United
States right but he's doing it because
it's a calling from within I'm called
from within to train people help them in
property they so I'm I'm I'm called from
within to help business maybe you're
called from within to be a political
leader or campaigner these people that
are holding these foot boards and flags
they are absolutely broke every single
one of them have no money but that's
their beliefs isn't it
they've got beliefs as well they should
not be standing here I mean like some
when something's voted in light brings
it if it's about even if you don't agree
with it how I grew up my city for years
dealing with that but yeah people have
got their own it they've got that most
what makes the world go round
yeah I mean for me right I don't really
care about if different peoples with
different political perspectives or
unbreak there or I don't mind that I
think that the people the people that
make the rules are the same people that
make money in property yeah
and just figure out the rules later
Thema in the UK it's a brilliant place
to invest whether it's stocks and shares
or property and stuff like that yeah and
I think it's easier than any other
country in the world to make money of
your investment probably but I'm being a
business owner it's things that the
people behind us make decisions that a
stopping business fishing fireman I've
already given you my green stamp but I'm
also an investor of property oh no no
stop property
both of us have got well I know you know
I've got a multi-million pound proximal
photos residential and commercial I know
that you have to i-i've never moaned
about property investment it's the
people that want to employ people the
people that want to start businesses it
is much harder to be a business owner
than a property investor I grew down I
think property is I get annoyed when I
get annoyed that I've made most of my
wealth today I haven't realized from our
businesses yet that I've made more
wealth from property without employing
people yeah without having any stress
you just buy property ten years later
the bloody things doubled imagine all of
this rent and he's just like this is how
come this you're easier than being a
business or some pretty big businesses
yeah you've got like play 250 staff 12
million pound turnover the full work and
you might love property more I love
property I love business and I love my
property business entrepreneur I love
that I love property more than anything
you're a business owner so now I got
staff I'm a business owner but it's
talking about 30 seriously small really
I mean I don't want to have most people
don't employ you you know that the harsh
facts about 70% of businesses in the UK
don't even pay v18
30% pay the 80 so if you're paying v80
as a business owner you're in the top
third percent in size of this high
property then what do you think of Boris
coming in do you think it will have a
positive or a negative even though
you're supposed to ask me the questions
yeah positive or negative impact on
property Boris who else you do you think
Boris is gonna have a positive on Higa
to effect on property do you think
you're the loudmouth around things would
be positive Ida why do you think sir
because his optimism energy is a
center-right wing and he believes in
investments he wants to build more how
Jeremy Corbyn if he got in although
although I say we create our own economy
if he begotten I would have been a bit
worried because politics had a part do
worry about that man yeah I do because
when you start doing things like capping
rents
yeah like it's just completely every
time people every time you over regulate
an industry and put so many rules in you
destroy it
yeah what what do you think of Boris
because Boris is trying to abolish the
stamp duty ball but let's bring it down
which is fantastic you know this right
yeah I think we should reduce
temperatures it's a complete and that's
a fast pipe off you know I think I think
we should reduce damages okay it's a
complete and that's a farce it's a hook
conference so on the other business run
what and especially first-time buyers
and people just start that war is it's
so hard to tell us that tell us tell us
what what's in this letter and what are
you wanting to see cut v80 the archaic
business rates can lead complete and
utter reform yeah business rates are
stopped in physical locations businesses
setting up people or going into a bigger
warehouse opening up coffee shops on
High Street site that's stopping them
taking action because it's so archaic
and out of control talk to me about
brexit do you think the bourret do you
think Boris will get us out in three
months
I think he's got more of a chance than
lysosome oh I think you will it did you
see a speech that he did he's a fabulous
presenter and Paul's people and I think
he's got his flaws but haven't we all
and I don't think it's a detail person
at all so if we leave brexit in three
months what's gonna happen to the
property market in the UK well if it
drops I'll be by and I'll even do some
residential stuff in you really yeah I'm
looking forward I mean not matter I'm
sure you're the same if property values
drop both of us will probably lose
millions of bounds in terms of equity
you know it's all about cash flows big
time I'll be in negative equity yeah and
I don't care no because I want to buy
time I never get Brits right I don't
want people are so obsessed in this
country about what the value of their
properties are because they never bloody
sell other things the people that
benefit are their kids when they die
they sell the things and benefit from
the money yeah most Brits you know they
they value their wealth on their
I'm their what their property is worth
and that it's just I just never think
whatever is all about cash flow
absolutely cash is king
you know because you murder if you're if
you're a typical Brit and you never sell
your property what's it matter well it's
worth it yeah I'd be much I always talk
about rent roll yeah that's that's
that's the thing I want to boast about
what's your rent roll and I'm like damn
that's good
what the hell I've got this much equity
in my outlets who cares yeah for like a
big rent row online hello I think that
with with with with rent role I think
that we've rent roll even rent roll it's
not about rent roll it's about cash flow
because a lot of my properties HMOs and
I'm I have a high rent roll but I got a
lot I got to pay the bills and the
council you're on 20% return investment
that's your sort of yeah yeah I agree
and I also have this other rule that I
use 10% rent on total capital deployed
so my money and banks money so if I'm
put in buying a something for a million
quid I need to get a hundred thousand
pound a year bread and then the 20
percent ROI combined I try and get some
of the fits post so what you're saying
is we're here at Downing Street if
Briggs it makes property prices go right
down actually that's gonna help with my
buy low rent high strategy it's going to
mean that you get higher ROI it's also
going to help first-time buyers that as
you want to buy their first properties
but that's it is but that's the thing
you know what rather than trying to
change rather than trying to change the
rules or you know campaign or change the
economy you're better off to say what
are the rules and how can I play the
game to win because the same people that
make the rules are the same people that
make money most of the time anyway in
property specifically so what are the
rich people doing what are the
successful people doing and and and if
there's anyone rich in the country if
people say oh this doesn't work in
America this doesn't work in Africa this
is like what are they rich people in
Africa yes therefore just do what
they're doing unless they inherited it
do what they're doing and you can be
rich so whatever the economy's doing
wherever you are
unless it's absolutely Plains or
something you can usually just learn the
rules be fluid
have a fluid strategy and make my living
the thing is about how you feel about
this
this is a question I asked you I think
entrepreneurial ISM and that is a DNA
thing which you have definitely got yeah
but I don't we actually I think you can
learn it that there's a base talent I
think you can learn to get better but
there's a base talent you can never go
if you're a singer for example yeah you
can't you can never make me sing well
even if you give me the best singing
teacher in the world
yeah I haven't got that bass talent now
if you've got some bass talent like
David Beckham bass time and flipper like
give him an Alex Ferguson and it becomes
world-class
you've got most talent but here's what I
think I've got by I've got bass talent
and I learn and I work hard that's why
we're very wealthy but I think that
anybody even if not absolutely that's
what I respect about you mate it's
because you always ask me of you know my
opinion and I always ask you of European
just not many people do that when they
get to a certain level of success is the
thing right even if you even if you've
got no bass talent you can still in my
opinion not become a multi
multi-millionaire but you can become
financially free pop I completely agree
and that's what I teach
I completely agree but some people like
you would have a problem boring ten
million pounds and sleeping at night nor
would I yeah
other people just can't get their head
around pourings might think yeah I can
borrow a million pounds and I'm I'm okay
with that different risk appetite some
do yeah but I think the economy is gonna
be good here I think that I mean I know
people are talking about leaving the EU
as if it's gonna mean that suddenly we
shrivel and die I think I things pretty
off the EU won't be there in 30 to 40
years anyway probably not it's not gonna
be there it's just well when was when
was the EU established 1970-something
well before though he was still Great
Britain right yeah we were still doing
all right we do really work we're not we
need to be thinking global not so
European and we need to be friends with
our partners in Europe but we need that
I mean India China you have Brazil that
the South America's is South Africa's
they're gonna be the the emerging
economies would be then that Ryan
lettuce is okay I get why you've written
your letter we're gonna we've put a link
we put a link in the description about
why you've written your letter I get
that but I think that you should spend
your time and effort
focusing on you and your business and
your family not watching the news
worried about the politicians want to
change from when I talk about you but I
know so many broke-ass campaigners so
many poor people that they and they know
they know everything they know
every time Donald Donald Trump tweets
they what they read it every time boy
they watch the news every day and
they're so broke because all that time
and energy that they're spending
complaining about the economy they
should be putting that effort into their
own business absolutely absolutely cool
I agree with that wholeheartedly let us
know your thoughts man what do you think
of Boris Johnson what do you think about
brexit do you think it's gonna have a
positive or a negative impact on
property investing in the UK comment
below if you've got questions dropping
below as well check out chapman at my
man James Sinclair awesome guy good
friends and don't forget to subscribe
smash that like button and I'll see you
next time see you Kang